welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how
zack snyder's dceu vision is actually
perfect
so long as you keep up with the comments
screenshots from vero
you know it's not that hard if you were
a true fan you would already know this
with zack snyder's justice league we
think only weeks away from its premiere
on hbo max we're gonna break down the
complete dceu
timeline what happened to this promising
franchise
and you know thanks to the snyder cut
and a couple other titles maybe james
gunn suicide squad the flash movie
starring michael keaton
the dceu can be saved folks its best
days
may still be ahead we're gonna explain
how that will happen i'm eric boss here
with me today
is zach huddleston hey man hey thanks
for having me eric
i'm here to uh represent zach's the
world over
uh be they schneiders or huddle weapons
i've got my uh
hat turned backwards like it's time to
do business and because i haven't had a
haircut in a really long time
yeah it's the ash ketchum rule of
getting serious
yeah and you were here i believe last
time we talked about the dc eu
in a big question episode we talked
about the kill counts between batman and
v superman uh it's very interesting to
look at that crimtonian genesis
uh chamber to see if you know those
counts as lives they don't count they
weren't fertilized
uh life life begins in pod that sounds
like a great podcast about abortion that
i won't listen to
thank you for having me back i have a
big question i want to propose to you
how did the dceu get so [ __ ] up
and how can the snyder cut restore it to
its rightful glory
it's good that we're talking about this
it's a fascinating tale
the tale of the dceu let's start with uh
some background how do we get
this point in the dc eu to where we need
the snyder cut this weird hbo max
experiment to see if we can save it well
let's rewind
the clock back to christopher nolan's
dark knight trilogy
super successful um broke records
it was amazing we can agree to that but
uh nolan if you remember
outright refused to put superman or
anyone with actual superpowers in his
movies he wanted a grounded vision he
wanted everything to be grounded in uh
in science uh in logic except for when
it comes to the dark knight rises how
batman can
heal his back in a week all your money
20 minutes later
uh after the dark knight trilogy warner
brothers sought to reboot the dc lineup
as a cinematic universe
they've been trying to do that for years
and they saw what was happening at
marvel and they're like
why are they successful we have better
characters let's do our version of it
and show them how it's done
and the first title on this was man of
steel
that was zack snyder's uh relaunch of
the dc eu as it became known to be
called
uh man of steel rebooted the superman
mythology really if you think about it
as an
immigrant story henry cavill was great
the production designers are really
great about sneaking in a ton of dc
easter eggs there was ace chemicals
there was luther corp everywhere the
little batman clues
zack snyder talked about how they left
one of those kryptonian pods
open when uh khalil found it hinting at
another kryptonian's existence on earth
maybe supergirl it really felt like you
were joining
a a broader world it was really fun uh
and it ended up wrecking in huge
portions of metropolis and it forced
superman to snap zod's neck
controversial but emotionally justified
what did you think of man of steel's act
i liked it it did i mean it had been a
while since we've seen a superman movie
at that point
right since the brandon routh one off
and it was refreshing to see
our old cape buddy back in action sure i
i
kind of agreed with some of the you know
people who thought it was a slightly
bloodier take than we might have needed
but
it felt like okay this is the superman
equivalent to the
christopher nolan batman i think we are
all at least
willing to see what zack snyder had up
his sleeve next cause the guy
is a very good technical director he
knows how to compose a shot he can
compose some really really beautiful
sequences on screen so that led warner
to approve
a justice league lineup of films under
snyder's vision
but the next movie would not come out
for another three years so to make up
for that wait the next title was really
dc's biggest fan service swing of all
time or at least to date
batman be superman dawn of justice zach
do you remember
2013 comic-con when uh when zack snyder
showed the superman crises are going to
do another superman movie and then the
bat sigil
shadowed up behind it everyone lost
their minds
oh my god yeah that was i
i have a very vivid memory of that exact
thing you just described
i was like they're actually doing it and
they got a great cast in here
so this movie was going to launch the
justice league
it was going to bring in lex luthor it
was going to introduce a new
older grizzled batman played by ben
affleck
it was going to clash the two biggest
names in comics it
really can't be overstated how exciting
this was for dc fans
however when the trailers started to
come out a lot of us got worried
because warner was just showing so much
in these trailers they were giving it
all away
uh they were showing how a wonder woman
arrives which was like one of the
coolest moments of the movie they put in
the trailer
doomsday they put in the trailer which
basically told us that superman was
gonna die
when batman v superman eventually
released in march 2016
you know when i went to go see it the
movie looks beautiful it opens with this
one of my favorite sequences uh this
dramatic point of view shift for the
battle metropolis
from angry angry angry ben affleck bruce
wayne
it looks great it's so dramatic and
heart pounding
the duel between bruce and clark as they
were going layer by layer
blow for blow was pretty cool but i mean
you know we're not gonna go
over what the problems were this movie
we know there were some muddy plot
points
the ultimate edition did help clear a
lot of that up i would say ultimately
didn't entirely fix
but it did clear up a lot of the
questions i had coming out of the
theatrical
cut now in this one the easter eggs were
awesome there was this creepy easter egg
of a
dead robin's suit in the bat cave that
had hahaha jokes on you batman
saying the joker killed robin now we
thought it was a nod to joker killing
jason todd like the death in the family
comic but
uh snyder actually later clarified that
the dead robin was dick grayson
there was also that creepy nightmare
sequence with a post-apocalyptic earth
post dark side because it had the omega
symbol there an
evil superman and then bruce woke up
from that dream to still be what
seemed like a dream a visit by a time
traveling flash
who tells bruce that he was right about
him
referring to clark and that lois was the
key seems like this is about to get
revisited in the snyder cut we'll get
back to that so just to kind of recap
what this film gave us zack snyder
promised us
one uh coming conflict with darkseid and
steppenwolf to
the resurrection of superman in his
black suit in the next movie
three the justice league lineup wonder
woman flash aquaman cyborg
uh and maybe future prospects like green
lantern martian manhunter for
a distant post-apocalyptic future with
evil superman that the flash would have
to fix
via what we assumed would be a
flashpoint paradox
insane step in the movie franchise
unfortunately
in justice league we didn't get none of
that uh hopefully we'll get it back
in the fixed version it does seem and
you're gonna get into this when you talk
about justice league here in a moment
right that like this is where the dceu
diverges
between what it snyder had originally
planned for the entire thing and
what we ended up getting right would you
say that this is the main fork in the
road
yes i think it was right around here
where like warner did not know what to
do
with that film they rather just trust
dan snyder
to just kind of carry out his vision for
better or worse
they started to meddle and they started
to tinker but they also saw some success
in other releases and i think they
learned the wrong lessons from those and
that started with suicide squad which
i would say is a movie that we're
excited about but suffered from
warner's expectation game like batman v
superman did i think you remember david
ayer's early trailer it got really mixed
reactions there was that line from will
smith who's like so
some kind of suicide squad and
everyone's like oh come on seriously
uh ladies and gentlemen if you will look
right here
but then uh a twist in spring 2016 they
hired a new trailer cutting company who
edited a trailer to sync with bohemian
rhapsody and
that was one of the coolest trailers
ever the reaction was
too good though because then warner's
like oh okay okay okay
we'll just let this company re-edit the
entire film and then
a lot of stuff got lost right uh air
never really got his final cut
and then the movie ended up being a
super colorful crazy soundtrack
chaotic mess uh it does kind of tie into
the dceu they have these splashy title
cards where they
reveal that harley quinn helped kill
robin ben affleck batman actually shows
up
in these flashbacks to apprehend jared
leto joker and harley quinn
ezra miller flash shows up arresting
captain boomerang but the plot
zach i'm sorry this movie is just kind
of nonsensical the way it was released
theatrically
a lot of the cast spins the final battle
just like watching stuff happen
joker dies it seems like but then comes
back to life to break out harley quinn
in the end never explained which is why
a lot of fans are now demanding the air
cut
not not to get too movie criticy here
well this is a great time for you to
stick your foot potentially in your
mouth
again eric as somebody who's who's maybe
not super enthusiastic about the snyder
cut what are your thoughts on a
potential a or cut
i mean look if the snyder cut existed in
some form the air cut exists in some
form right he has i
i like i think zack snyder knew what he
wanted to do
with justice league more than a or knew
what he wanted to do with suicide squad
i'll just say that
i am more excited by james gunn's the
suicide squad than whatever ayer had in
the works and i kind of want to see
what was with it and then we can see
what happens on the other side and it
seems like that's what warner brothers
thought as well right like there are no
next justice league movies planned
they're they're investing their time and
resources into the snyder cut
right whereas there's about to be
released a brand new
suicide squad movie right but let's talk
about wonder woman in 2017.
uh this movie of course you remember a
flashback to world war one it was
inspired by that 1918 photo that bruce
wayne found of diana that he gave to her
in batman v superman
in this movie diana saves chris pine and
steve trevor from some germans and then
she crosses into no man's land it's
pretty cool
she defeats her uncle aries though steve
has to give up his own life
really what i think a lot of people
forget is that wonder woman opened with
this cool
new dc cinematic fanfare that promised a
wide range of possible film adaptations
we saw like nightwing green lantern
corps
gotham city sirens mr freeze i was so
pumped to see
what all like i was waiting for the day
in like 2025 when i could go back and
like to say
they ended up doing this one and this
one and this one this one they got to
all of it but here's the problem zack uh
warner learned the wrong lesson from
wonder woman's success
i think the studio was so thrilled with
the response to that movie
that they just like clung to it as this
backup plan to just keep
pumping out loosely connected dceu
charming movies
but without any broader vision of how it
would connect to anything else
but if you already kind of make the
promise of your audience that some of
this is going to connect
they start to hold it to a higher
standard of interconnectivity so you
can't really have it both ways you have
to either make
elseworld uh anthology type movies or
you can make something to where it's
like the mcu where everything is
connected and i think that is why
we're seeing a lot of the reactions to
wonder woman 84 i think
fans are confused and they're rightly
confused because the studio set up the
sequel
to be very confusing so i just want to
keep track of some of maybe the lessons
learned here eric
not a great sign when you keep recutting
a movie
separate from the original movie's
director right
not a great sign when maybe you take the
wrong lessons from both the excitement
around a trailer
and around kind of like a big hit or
even
the lesson you take away from maybe an
underwhelming hit right like
some of a lot of people have interpreted
the box office returns of batman vs
superman
impacted warner brothers future decision
making because that movie was not a huge
kind of financial success right yeah it
made a lot of money just not as much as
they wanted it to
yeah yes and so there were i i guess
earlier i said this is the fork in the
road but it seems like the fork keeps
forking
right this is a whole fork and mess
right here
which leads us to the justice league
theatrical cut
later in the year 2017. that's where the
fork of the road just caused the train
to derail
and smash into a school and just keep
going and going and going
until it runs over a delorean and we
can't go back in time anymore
because the flash isn't in movies
so i'll say this about justice league
zack snyder had
i remember um 2016 comic-con zack snyder
released
a trailer for this movie and people were
like whoa whoa whoa whoa you already
have all this footage to give us
and i got so excited the vision seemed
so promising the
cast seemed fully fleshed out that the
tone seemed already there
and i was excited to see what he was
going to do with this he put together
what was like a several hour crazy cut
of the movie
and then in early 2017 tragedy struck
with his family his daughter died
uh so he stepped down from production uh
so then the studio
afraid that this kind of the movie is
gonna be too dark or too gritty
but really the problem was the studio
didn't know what they wanted
they didn't know what they didn't want
they didn't know what they wanted what
do you want
it's not that simple what do you want
they were just kind of reacting to
everything
and they ended up handing the movie over
to joss whedon
thinking he would just fix everything
because hey it's a guy who did the
avengers he knows what he's doing
reshooting a lot of it and then the
result was a cut that
left the movie's mythology completely
undeveloped
the vfx was just like potatoey
we all remember the reshoots with henry
cavill that forced him to cgi over his
mustache
he gave him that really goofy looking
upper lip you won't let me live
you won't let me die it's like you
didn't need that scene did not need to
be in the movie at all like there's just
a lot of
huh like really that's our justice
league huh
so all of snyder's plans for justice
league part two
that we're gonna bring in darkseid and
then we're gonna circle back to that
nightmare sequence
and that flashpoint set up all that was
scrapped there was this post-credits
scene with lex luthor and joe
meganello's deathstroke that
maybe was gonna set up a deathstroke as
the ben
affleck batman solo film villain but
then that film was scrapped when
they couldn't agree on a version of the
project that ben affleck was okay with
are gonna be directing batman
potentially that's the idea
the idea is there's no movie you know
yet it's not a movie but
there is the plan to make a batman movie
and they kind of went back to square one
with that then going to matt reeves who
reconceived it as a new robert pattinson
the batman which looks great but
it's just in a different world meanwhile
everything seemed to be tail spinning uh
there was a planned harley quinn joker
rom-com spin-off from the this is us
creators that was canceled
along with a jared leto joker solo film
cancelled
[Music]
really it just left the todd phillips
walking phoenix joker ago because it was
super low budget
and they moved forward and that ended up
like winning oscars and making a crap
ton of money
meanwhile the dominant dcu narrative for
the next few years
was when will warner brothers release
the snyder cut
and zack you remember where we're at
with that we were like is this a real
story
as you pointed out a couple times it was
hard to tell is this a
very small contingent of super
passionate people who are kind of
clinging to this idea
right or is this a real movement with
with enough people behind it and kind of
the public momentum
don't you think it was kind of it was a
dark period i mean then multiple
uh ways for the dc eu right after
justice league comes out and really
nobody was happy with it right the the
hardcore fans the general public right
and so it's like they need something to
look forward to
and like this was kind of the light
i know this last movie was not what we
wanted but that's because
you know it was mishandled by joss
whedon and boy when you think about it
they really couldn't have hired a worse
person
now and this isn't even ray fisher over
here talking about like the various
harmful behaviors on set but like joss
whedon a guy who's like
made a similar movie and so has this
very distinct vision if they would have
just kind of hired a journeyman
director to come in and take it across
the finish line right
grab some european guy who knows how to
do a good tracking shot
and just let him get that last 20 out
that snyder was able
unable to finish but instead they bring
in this very specific
determined successful director who
reshapes the entire thing in his image
and it just
turns into a mess this is the best
version of
me that i can explain so then there was
this kind of awkward year
throughout 2018 it ended with aquaman
coming out um
and that was james wan's undersea origin
story for arthur curry jason momoa in
kind of a royal conflict with his
half-brother orm
patrick wilson and that was kind of set
up by the fact that arthur had this
five-pronged
trident to dent whatever uh of his
mother
in justice league it was atlanta's uh so
he kind of inherited it but
in the aquaman movie we see him
acquiring the three-prong trident of his
ancestor king atlan to become
the true orange and green suited aquaman
and there weren't really a ton of dc
eu easter eggs and aquaman i remember
there was more like james one easter
eggs there was like annabelle showed up
in there uh but i don't remember seeing
a lot of like oh this is how that
connects to that it was like james one
was just staring clear of a lot of it
and so much that movie took place
underwater so it's easy to avoid like a
random flash spotting
if you're in the marianas trench or
whatever now a couple months later
shazam came out
which you know that movie kind of came
and went because 2019 was obviously a
huge year for comic book movies
but i really like david sandberg i love
his horror film work and he kind of did
this homage to big
zach levi was the adult billy batson
shazam and i kind of liked it
it felt like an old school superhero
movie that was funny it was charming and
the way it connected to the dceu i
thought was really clever because it was
just kind of like the way fanboys
connect to it like freddie freeman was
obsessed with the justice league heroes
he wears
shirts and jackets for all of them he
has merch all over his the shelves he
has like newspaper clippings from past
events
so it feels like it's in the world but
that's not like it serves the character
it's not just like forced in
and then we all remember the final scene
of that features a cameo by superman but
it was like a headless superman because
they couldn't get henry cavill to do it
uh so we just see his body coming with
john williams superman theme and we
don't see his head
which i assume he was headless and i
will say i i agree that shazam movie was
so much fun
and it it was nice in that it it took
like the fun montages of some of these
other
superhero movies and just like really
embraced those
and kind of almost like stretch those
yeah each length it was that movie was a
good time
yeah it was enjoyable um 2019 ended
though a very interesting moment for the
dc eu a movie that's not part of the
dceu joker
a complete surprise monster success this
thing broke uh box office records i
think it's the
uh highest grossing r-rated movie of all
time won awards
one oscars it is not at all connected to
dcu it's really uninterested in dc
mythology it's really more of like a
mental illness character study kind of
like taxi driver
do you think you're talking to with a
fight club style unreliable narrator
that's right but the thing with joker
was it gave the studio a path
forward without the dceu they started to
wonder well do we need this
interconnectivity if we can do very low
budget movies
and make ten times as much back around
the same time
uh the cw did the crisis on infinite
earths that was the arrow versus
flash versus the berlanti shows uh their
annual crossover event but they
connected it to the dceu in a really fun
way they had a cameo by ezra miller
barry allen
and many of us believe that we could see
the mirror side of it in the upcoming
flash movie
and then moving right along to uh birds
of prey one of the only movies sticking
out in 2020 theatrically
really this is just an excuse to bring
back margot robbie as harley quinn from
suicide squad and try to make her
what i think was the deadpool of the dc
eu she was
freshly broken up with mr j and we
really only see him i think in the form
of a doodle there were some customary dc
background set easter eggs ace chemicals
showed up again
but the only one of imports of the dcu
going forward
was this wanted poster for captain
boomerang which signaled to us
that he uh must have escaped from prison
and that he would show up in some
suicide squad in the future
i i enjoyed it also um one of the best
uh egg sandwich cameos
in any movie i've seen in a long time
egg bacon
american cheese cash of hot sauce
it's hard to find a good breakfast
sandwich in la people want their nice
cute instagrammy brunches not their like
sloppy greasy
wrapped bodega sandwiches eating crap
with these sacks of [ __ ]
if they died tomorrow no one would shed
a tear so cute
hey if you live in la you know where to
find a good breakfast sandwich let me
know i
found a cafe tropical in los feliz and i
found hank's bagels
in tuluk lake which has a great bagel
breakfast right down the street from me
you actually live above it don't find me
so that brought us to the present a
wonder woman 1984.
this movie i have some mixed feelings
about it really just ignored
dcu continuity altogether which at this
point i bet the filmmaker just thought
that no one really remembers what the
rules are
diana can fly in this movie despite not
flying decades later
the world undergoes an insane nuclear
crisis
based on max lord's genie magic monkey
paw law
life is good but it can be better that
would not have left the world as it was
a man of steel and batman v superman i'm
sorry it's just insane really these past
couple dceu titles just feel like
obligatory sequels and spin-offs that
were just eagerly greenlit
after modest fan approval in the past
without any broader creative goal to
them and that's just because
warner alienated their key visionary to
unite all this stuff zack snyder and
jeff johns
hasn't been able to communicate a
unifying vision that can get the studio
and the filmmakers
united behind so it's just kind of a
confusing place where it's at right now
however the dc eu
appears to be headed for a possible
rebirth
and i'm not talking about the dc rebirth
i'm talking about a dc eu rebirth my
friends starting with
zack snyder's justice league coming to
hbo max sometime this year we think as
soon as march
and zack snyder has promised to restore
his original vision we're gonna see some
deleted sequences featuring ray fisher's
performance as cyborg
uh we're gonna see black suit superman
dark sides backstory the whole nightmare
future
flash is going to use the speed force to
travel through time
we think it looks like a very different
tonal experience that
might hit a lot of the same story beats
as a theatrical cut
but it's going to put them in a much
more i think satisfying
context uh but zach let's talk about how
the snyder cut
uh could fix the dceu one
it could set up flashpoint and set up
the upcoming flash movie
which can then use time travel in the dc
multiverse to resolve
all past plot holes i'm telling you once
we clear the air
everybody's going to be pals again the
second way can fix it can kind of turn
the page it can give the proper send off
to
henry cavill or ben affleck in a way
that doesn't make their era feel like a
mistake
you can kind of create a new 52 reset
for dc cinematic going forward
however it could also bring back caval
it could reopen the door for henry
cavill to return as superman the guy was
great i would say after zack snyder
cavill seems like the most underused
talent from this franchise
and zack you asked about this earlier
but this could lead to
more director cut series i am someone
who loves every cut of everything every
version every deleted scene i'll watch
it all
right and if the snyder cut it's an
interesting experiment it could lead to
a surge of subscriptions to hbo max
and if hbo is happy with it if warner's
happy hell
let's see that air cut a suicide squad
whatever it is let's see it
and let's see ben affleck's vision for
the batman
where's the batman i'm working
give me a second like if fans want it if
the director's on board
if it can be done on budget you know via
animation or storyboards do a
documentary series do live readings
there are lots of ways this vision
could move forward it's deep fake deep
fake ben affleck
onto robert pattinson for every shot of
the battery
you know it's good to have dreams now
here's what i'm worried about the dcu
here are the challenges to
to fixing the dc eu because i think
warner could get greedy
uh and cash in with more sequels and
spin-offs that don't really make sense
like we got a sequel to aquaman coming
late 2022 maybe early 2023
we got shazam period the gods coming
2023.
they recently greenlit a third wonder
woman movie
patty jenkins might not come back for
that one and then we got the shazam spin
off black adam white wade wilson
starring dwayne the rock johnson
now if you are excited about any of
these titles i don't want to take any of
your excitement
they could all be fantastic movies but
here's what's scary about it they really
really really need the snyder cut in
suicide squad and
at least a flash trailer to keep the fan
thirst
alive for these titles because otherwise
this is a big challenge with the dcu
when your characters are out of sight
they're out of mind
you don't have like two to three movies
a year to remind us all that these
characters exist
when you have two to three movies a year
like the mcu does you have a ton of
trailers coming out you have tie-in
series coming out
like fans don't forget people exist
whereas you know when these movies
returned like a 11184
trailer came out i was like oh you know
that model from four years ago is doing
something new now but
here's the challenge for the snyder cut
if the snyder cut and let's say the
suicide squad and the flash
are earth shatteringly successful enough
that could convince warner and hbo max
att their parent company
to keep that cinematic universe alive in
a different form even if it's just on
hbo max
they did already say that they plan to
release a couple movies theatrically
every year and then a couple movies just
on the streaming platform
that could be where the dceu lives on
and i wouldn't have a problem with that
as long as we can get it we can get to
it faster if it releases on
my tv at home and then maybe some of
them are so good you also do
a theatrical release and i'll pay to see
it in the theater like the flash could
be so insanely good that we are now
excited to see these aquaman
could have just peed on it and then
shazam and wonder woman sequels and
spin-offs that we're gonna get i like we
wanna see what those characters do
post-crisis
ultimately though zach i think we might
finally see a live-action dc lineup that
does fulfill the promise of that 2017
fanfare of all the characters i think at
the end of the day that's all we really
want
hmm that's interesting because you know
where my gut instinct says
in a time when marvel is condensing
right it used to be like
the netflix marvel world or agents of
shield they were kind of slightly
separate from the film versions right
but now no there is only one marvel
now right the anything streaming
anything on tv
any film are all going to exist in the
exact same universe there's part of me
that's like
dc should swerve hard in the other
direction and i want a thousand
different universes
right the flash doesn't need to take
place in the same place in the same
world as aquaman
or future justice leagues or the batman
or whatever right like
give give us as superhero
movie consumers right more options
rather than just two well and that's the
argument for letting
the flash be a flashpoint story that can
do that can
just restore it into kind of a new 52
that don't always connect you know maybe
the flash ends
with like this is the climax of the dceu
these characters are done
and then now they don't have to
reference each other ever again
um until later somewhere down the line
someone wants to take another shot
at doing justice league uh maybe a zack
snyder maybe it's someone else who
learns from his vision and tries to
improve upon it or go in a different
direction
but i think he deserves his opportunity
to tell the vision he want to tell he's
getting it and that's great
and i think it could really set up flash
to be
like the distillation of that that
connects
everything together and then never again
i love it
i like that but we'll see uh let us know
what you want the future of the dceu to
be in the comments below
we're gonna move on to some friends who
helped us make this episode first we
want to thank our friends at amazon
pharmacy for sponsoring this episode of
big question take a break from streaming
the newest season of the boys
or buying a new gadget and check out the
pharmacy section of amazon trust me on
this
amazon pharmacy is the super easy way to
save time
and money and not have to wait in line
at the actual physical pharmacy which
i freaking hate i hate i hate being
inside anywhere right now especially
around people who need medications to
feel better
uh and uh and it's just i don't like it
um well amazon pharmacy coordinates with
your doctor to receive your
prescriptions and then they deliver
those medications right to your door
they work with most insurance plans it's
awesome i'm already buying stuff on
amazon because of the convenience and
the easy delivery
it just makes sense do the same with
prescriptions doesn't it something i
don't want to worry about running
out of let's be honest uh pharmacy
errands are among the least fun errands
uh
up there with trips to the post office
or like contesting a parking ticket
uh wisdom tooth removal i hate that
errand it's it's so painful
take one of those pains off your to-do
list
with amazon pharmacy amazon prime
members can save on prescription
medication when not using insurance and
get
free two-day delivery learn more at
amazon.com
big question rx that's a-m-a-z-o-n
dot com slash big question rx amazon.com
bigquestionrx zack we're getting bezos
money now
yeah now all we got to do is get elon
musk money and we'll have uh
the two no the world's two richest man
in our back pocket
and then we'll gradually drain them dry
oh and also just exited for snyder cut
in case you don't speak french obviously
i don't either but that translates to i
am excited for snyder cut and i just
learned it from babble
the number one selling language learning
app thank you to babel for sponsoring
this episode a big question
folks i would love to get to travel to
europe someday and i want to be able to
chat with the new nerd friends in their
native tongue
well babel has made that language
learning process addictively
fun and easy with bite-sized lessons
that you are
going to actually use in the real world
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go
while you're waiting in a drive-through
line or during a commercial break
unlike those language classes that you
took from high school and block out as i
do most of my high school memories
babel designs their courses with
practical real world conversations in
mind things that you will use in
everyday life their teaching method has
been scientifically proven to be
effective with babble you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
which i should probably open up another
lesson because obviously my french needs
work
right now when you purchase a month
babel subscription you will get an
additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use their promo
code big
question that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code big question for an extra three
months free
battle language for life all right now
we're going to move on to some
bite-sized question that zach's going to
answer for us you ready zach
absolutely all right our friend actually
sauceless again from discord asks
in avengers end game when thor summons
his hammer in the past
what would have happened if 2013 thor
tried summoning it at the same time
would it go to whomever is worthier or
does it just stop in place
being pulled in both directions i love
it and you know the worthiness
of mjolnir is such a fun topic
right it's one of the the most
interesting things within the mcu
because it's evolved a little bit over
time and god has there ever been a
moment better
than cap wielding mjolnir in that final
battle and end game
i mean i could watch that video of the
theater crowd
cheering when that happens on loop make
me smile all day long
[Applause]
this particular question is really fun
and quick shout out to actually
sauceless
sauce or saucy bobby the entire uh sauce
first
on discord um i like this question
because it
it applies not only to older thor versus
young thor
right but thorver's cap since in game
you know established cap is as worthy uh
and that battle was like this insane
melee right where there's
moving bodies and and good guys are bad
guys flying around right
like both avengers would likely even
just instinctually have tried to
summon mjolnir at the same time right
out of each other's hands
yeah cap you know reaching back to whack
a dude and just
milder flies away and into thor's hand
son of a [ __ ] for gosh sake watch your
language
so i think it's important for us here to
define
worthiness in in this context right and
whether
worthiness is this kind of subjective
quality that can be
measured on a spectrum or is it like a
binary trait
a yes no kind of thing you're either are
worthy or not
or could you be you know somebody has to
fail yes welcome to worthiness school
and you fail yeah could somebody be a
9.2 of worthiness versus a 9.7 or
something like that right
if it is this kind of spectrum idea
right of it's it's a range much like uh
maybe sexuality or or autism or lots of
other things right
uh mjolnir in theory would give priority
to the most movie wielder right like
whoever is the most worthy
should two people be summoning it at the
same time it would fly to that person
right and you could argue that endgame
thor might have been the most worthy
right because if if 4-1 or thor dark
world thor
was worthy of mjolnir well he's only
experienced
more he's matured more he's learned more
about sacrifice
he had that great reconnection with uh
his mom
right like he went kind of through the
dark valley of uh
being fortnite thor he managed to summon
mjolnir in 2013 when he went back
to asgard from whoever had it in that
moment which in theory was 2013
thor right that's thor dark world era
thor and endgame thor is basically able
to snatch it
right from his grip so in theory endgame
thor more worthy than
dark world thor would you agree with
that i i would um you could say that
like
his uh retirement period made him less
worthy but i don't think so
i i think you're right the fact that he
could get it in that moment he realized
he was still worthy
and at least at after resolving issues
with his mother
he was probably at max worthiness that
it was his final form of worthiness
he must be finished transforming
he's technically more of everything in
endgame body mass
hair hand-eye coordination you could
also argue that
end game cap is more worthy than end
game thor
okay since thor right like we'd said
thor's been through some stuff he's at a
low point especially at the beginning of
end game
right he kind of gave up he let himself
go he's not in a maybe the best mental
state
you know he has magically braided his
beard but the beard's still there right
he's still a little rough he's still a
little bit in the wilderness
i'm completely lost
none of his avenger buddies were really
thor for that matter right like
trusted him to do the snap right they
gave that to hulk
right that says something about right uh
he's maybe not in the best place
mentally even though technically the
guy's a god
he should have been the one you know all
things being equal
you know snapping if we say and you know
that again the definition has changed
over time but like if as guardian worth
seems to respond to courage strength
resilience
selflessness right the ability to uh
with a willingness to sacrifice oneself
for your loved ones as thor showed us in
the very first thor movie right like
nobody embodies that better than cat and
he has not had the dark arc
of kind of like losing those qualities
right like throughout
the mcu appearance of captain america
right he's embodied
that worthiness yeah he's been pretty
steady simple life
and some have argued i like this
argument too and that that scene in age
of ultron
at the party scene where everybody's
like trying to you know pull up on
mjolnir and tony can't move it and
roadie can't move it
and uh bruce can't move it and and cap
wiggles it just a little bit
that that was cap holding back he knew
he could have picked it up but because
he's so worthy
he didn't want to make his buddy thor
feel bad
right he and in fact that's that proves
his worthiness
that he's not a showboater right that
like he doesn't want to do this he's
he he wiggled it almost by accident or
maybe in that tiny wiggle
he realized that he could do it and he
didn't want to right
because that's not his style yeah the
mcu has given no indication that anybody
can be more worthy than anybody else
right they haven't really shown us that
there's the scale
it seems like the mcu is probably on
this binary thing
right you know yeah i think so odin's
sweet little whisper
right cue the uh yin yang twins
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy right blah blah blah so it's
whosoever
it's not like if he be the most worthy
if he be a slightly
somebody else or whatever right it's
just you are you or not so thor is
worthy
boom cap is worthy right vision is
worthy
maybe not enough people talk about that
right homeboy vision just picking it up
now
you can make the argument it might have
been a joke that like vision is just an
elevator
right if you put mule near an elevator
and it went up a floor
you know that's basically what yeah he's
not a person so he's got a machine
like a forklift or whatever but odin is
worthy and technically hella
is worthy right hella destroyed that's
right the owner she catches it
destroys it now we could get into the
weeds here about like
worthiness to wield meow near versus
worthiness to have the powers of thor
right and they haven't gone into a ton
of detail there right to
totally like shoot the lightning and
access the bifrost and stuff like that
like
that might be an extra degree of
worthiness above just being able to hold
the hammer and
and crack somebody with it uh those are
the the kind of the four confirmed
people within the mcu that we know about
it right
and i think hella is the most
instructive one there
but let's say one of those summoners is
not evil you know
out for revenge hella but if it had been
cap
and end game thor trying to summon it at
the same time two
equally worthy people right
i think it comes back down to just dibs
right if if i happen to summon it a
fraction of a second ahead of you
eric right you being uh endgame thor and
me being
in game cap in this moment i get first
dibs right and then maybe once it comes
to me
maybe it could flow back to you who
knows we could make that argument right
but like i think
i think that's what it has to be and
even if it's a fraction of a millionth
of a second right
but i would say the problem is like
that's never gonna happen because if
you're worthy
you're okay with the hammer going to
someone else who's worthy you know so
it's like you're never going to get to
the situation where people are
equally wanting it they'd be like oh
yeah it's fine you take it
no you take it no you take it after you
oh no you first
i couldn't think of it if thor did
accidentally yank it out of his hand
because he needed it you know cap would
have been cool with that he would have
just started smashing guys with the
shield
and i think that is the fascinating part
of that hella moment of like before
thor can summon it back she destroys it
right so she never has that kind of like
which almost like
the action there's a lot of um catch 22s
with mjolnir in that like the action of
destroying it proves you're unworthy but
it's too late because it's already
destroyed
she was able to wield it before odin's
worthiness charm so she's kind of like
you know her wielding of it is different
it's not a worthy thing for her
she is just like she was there she was
kind of there it was originally hers to
begin with
so she's kind of like you know
grandfathered into that grandmother
grand grand grand guided uh in
grand wizard did it yeah oh neither um i
also i i do love
that like you know in the comics they
they obviously have more time to spend
on mjolnir
and and we could see this in thor 11th
under with jane foster
like mjolnir is almost like the
embodiment
it almost has a personality right
there's almost like some decision making
within
magic uh hammer and like the old bear
chooses to let jane foster
kind of wield it and it kind of forms
that partnership with her
and we know you know natalie portman is
gonna we saw that
comic-con moment right she's gonna wield
mjolnir
and so like it would be interesting if
they explore a little bit of that as
well
because it's magic you could do whatever
you want it's magic
shut up that is true um all right
another question
from manscapingpancakes on discord
asks in ant-man of the wasp scott lang
states that the largest size he's been
able to grow to
is 65 feet does he break that record
during the final battle of avengers
in-game if so by how much
okay and this is one of those great
questions that
we can really get specific with right
there's a great screenshot right when
everybody's coming through the portals
in that final
battle right there's giant scott
right and then down at it's at his feet
right there are human characters or
human sized
characters right and you can extrapolate
that he is 19 times taller
than the human character at his foot and
so
we don't know it's it's it's a zoomed
out shot you can't tell
is that black panther or you know
captain america or whoever we have no
idea who who the character is
but if you assume maybe an average
heighted
human male right it's about five nine
right so 19 times five nine would be
about 109 feet
tall 33 meters for okay in um
in the developed world so that is
that's almost double the height that
he'd achieved before
uh-huh which makes sense it's the
biggest battle in the history of the mcu
we need the biggest possible giant man
right but i think some people have made
the argument he actually might even be
taller than that
because right he holds hulk in the palm
of his hand
mcu hulk is usually considered to be
about seven five
somewhere between that and in eight feet
oh at least i think he's like 10 feet
that guy's a big dude
fair enough right and palm of his hand
right like like i would hold a baseball
or something like that so like
that and i think if we go back to that
image that we showed earlier
right some people have argued that
actually the little humans were might
even be standing
um closer to camera than scott right so
there's maybe even some perspective
issue there
and that those humans might not be
normal humans might not be americans
for that matter right they they're they
seem to be wakandan warriors
it seems like they got little spears
next to him right and if there were
condoms
from the jabari tribe right those are
some big people
okay and baku and his men are the
tallest the biggest
of the the wakandans right like winston
duke the actor who plays in baku
he's six five he doesn't even look like
the biggest jabari right like some of
them are
yeah are very large like if you assume
maybe the person's you know
standing on the ground next to scott
lang in that moment
might be seven feet tall oh well you
multiply that out times 19
right like you get to 133 feet
which is like okay drew like double the
previous
record of 65. that's big that's big no
that's gonna can you imagine the size of
the orange slice
scott is gonna need the next day after
getting that he's gonna take like a
month long nap after that that guy
didn't get
winded at all you know probably worth it
though to save half the people on earth
probably you know
it's okay to gas yourself out in that
moment i think
yeah double sounds good double sounds
good it sounds like the vfx guys dan
dillio was just like
uh let's make em double doubles big
this time yes times two everybody cab
gets to wield mjolnir
tony gets his big super heroic uh i'm
iron man moment
right let's go at least in the in the
background be twice as big as he's ever
gotten right
yeah scott in the background of the
in-game final battle is one of the best
parts about it it's like we get to see
true
giant man like punch in leviathans
shoving one through a portal so using
giving like a assist uh spider-man it's
great
it's when he shines right he's the best
possible background character
because he's the only one you can make
out you know besides maybe like
tiny like valkyrie like pegasus wings
you know it's like
that distance he's really the only uh
marvel character you can make out
all right well thank you zach well that
is it for this episode of big question
uh thank you to zach for joining me down
the rabbit hole of dcu history
uh yeah i pulled up my hammer earlier i
had a visual aid for the mjolnir topic
too late uh well uh be sure to follow
zack at z huddleston
follow me at eavos follow me rockstar
send us your big questions using the
hashtag bigquestions subscribe to this
podcast feed give us a nice reading
review if you don't mind
uh subscribe to rockstars here on
youtube hit that notification bell and
we will see you next time bye-bye
everybody
[Music]
you